Oh since I it's been a month without me
making videos see I can't even do an
intro how I make video I forgot how bad
welcome back to meme with you it's time
for me to understand what all the jokes
have been about what all you kids have
been laughing about while I've been away
I need to know I need to know please
it's not like it's gonna change do
something completely different in like
another there's been a couple of good
means however and we need to get into it
[Music]
hey remember when I said in my last
video there better not be any good memes
while I'm away let's start off by going
back baby Yoda it all started with baby
Yoda and then the concept spiral the way
with the peanut guy I don't remember his
name
peanut baby mr. peanut baby that doesn't
even make sense it's a baby you can't be
a mister and now I don't know where
comes ice age baby ice age baby god it
makes me sick just looking at it you're
looking at a stability
oh oh cringe ass ice baby I don't like
him I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna sit
here and pretend I don't know yeah I
would never of course incite violence
against anyone but if there was a
chamber and all I have to do was press a
button you know let's not get into it
but you know what I'm laying ice age
baby is blowing up right now you know
they just looked at kpop and was like
alright babies are popular kpop are
popular BAM we created this monstrosity
it didn't work work it was a massive
failure and I don't know this Ted how he
can fail really it looks so good
but he does not look like that come on
that is
[Music]
leafy level of chin come on man that's
right monsters me rap monster chin I
gotta look it up come on he has an
amazing chain is that him
BTS I am so confused they do cover it up
in this photo so maybe they were onto
something
Ice Age baby he's just eating a
watermelon dough some people are trying
to brainwash us into liking Ice Age baby
but a pure intellectuals wants to
curb-stomp the baby for my age me the
lads on our way 20th Century Fox Blue
Sky what the hell is this huh who
approved this by the way what kind of
computer generating graphics design
person generated this and thigh yeah
that's this good people are gonna love
Ice Age baby you know just an is it
racist to not like Ice Age baby maybe a
little bit but I think enough that it's
okay I think enough that it's okay if
you're one of the few minorities who
don't yet hate Ice Age baby I got bad
news for you that's right this just in
breaking news that baby from Ice Age
brutally attacked an 80 year old I just
think it's fun said the baby he just
thought it was fun huh well think about
how fun it is when actually people have
been tweeting about Ice Age baby
something saying that he looks like Adam
driver I don't see I don't see it looks
like the k-pop guys shut up I would beat
the freaking piss out of this idiot so
help me God the amount of rage that has
fill my body is unfathomable I wish your
dumb ass got frozen during the Ice Age
you poor excuse for a baby you he's just
eating a watermelon dough come on that's
what they want you to think huh they
just want you to think he's eating a
watermelon but no next thing you know
he's beating up your Adri old grandma
you don't want that to happen right only
I can beat up your a dear old grandma
everyone's saying they would forgot the
baby from is age but he fold your asses
like clean laundry physical attributes
new that Neanderthal that's the most
powerful race 610 why am I not in the
and earth all his name is squirt Jesus
Christ he needs to be stopped
Ice Age baby gets what he freaking
deserves nothing like a good dose of
for the baby from ice age to get me
through the day I love you almost as
much as I hate the baby from isolation
that's the line and I love my audience
to subscribe smash like me ice age baby
ah Whoopi Goldberg no that's not his
name
I remember wanted dead damn that was
even a there was even a petition that
was a petition to put down the baby from
my and it was removed once again
mainstream media is sensory I knew it I
knew it and YouTube's algorithm okay
just so we're clear this is joke all
right I would never hurt anyone except
Ice Age baby I never hurt anybody but if
I had a hammer and the Ice Age baby we
were sleeping in front of me I can't
guarantee its safety that's all I'm
gonna say if I was playing Minecraft
with Ice Age baby and we're on top of a
lava waterfall I can't guarantee I don't
make push inside Oh as a minecraft sound
happy birthday ice age baby I got you a
present cold hard steel ice age baby
you're not so freaking tough now are you
ice age baby why am I talking about ice
age your baby like I just come back from
breaking this it's so dumb ice age baby
retweet if you like this video if you
would beat the [ __ ] out of baby from Ice
Age
thank you guys appreciate it I rate this
meme send is age baby back to Isaiah out
of 10
thank you oh also I got a snack for the
baby from Ice Age
it's a knuckle sandwich stupid kid who
is responsible for a collapse of Soviet
Union I understand la no one can defend
this kid at this point shoot the Ice Age
baby get the chair yes sir yes leave a
comment right now you got five minutes
to answer I'll wait
I will not try and influence your
decision but will it do it thank you
thank you oh wait there's more Jesus
crippled fat don't bully him cool I'm
glad I came back from break to get
demonetised
alright once again asking your financial
support because this video is now
getting the monetize that was a
reference to our next meme next mean
damn that feels good that feels good not
gonna lie as the FEC fundraising
deadline for 2019 approaches I am once
again asking for your financial support
that's get that burning Sun well maybe
you shouldn't have roasted all those
millionaires and billionaires Bernie
Sanders huh this is a great meme I
really enjoyed this because it's such a
quotable sentence I am once again asking
your financial support it acknowledged
that you've done it before you don't
have to be the guy like oh geez here we
go again Bernie sander wants my money
showing up to my parents after spending
another month rent on weed and EDM
festivals I am once again asking your
financial support just want financial
support that's all I want and really why
this meme shines is its adaptability I
know this is an old meme I once again
review an old mean when you tell people
you just want cash for your birthday
that's pretty lame government when I
make money I once again asking for
financial support government when I buy
something government what I die this
meme has been sponsored by
libertarianism Thank You Bernie Sanders
I am once again asking you to release me
from these wack-ass crystal prison
Bernie Sanders I already helped you
escape from the octagon of doom it's not
gonna happen Bernie Sanders forget about
it I don't care how many times it
happens I am once again asking to see
the manager
Karen Bernice I know I'm once again
prepared for double trouble I am once
again asking why are we still here okay
all right show my grandma how to turn
off her Wi-Fi grandma five minutes later
and once again asking you for your
technical
I am neurons white I am Kira what I am
once again at soup Coll Millennials have
ruined the meemic yet again
congratulations shoutout to Millennials
you did it with your wacky quirky humor
well done applaud my bow my tip fedora
had to sing whatever you kids wear I
don't know hold on we have some video
footage what it means
we gotta get burning if you're listening
come on meme review we're a completely
politically neutral platform okay
come a meme review you will win the
election I guarantee it
I see election even happen I'm not
following I don't understand between us
name something an ex-girlfriend was
better at than your wife sexual
harassment
[Laughter]
all right Bernie you sold me you got my
financial support where can I donate it
was a great mean goddamn the effort
people put into these edits brah Bernice
ain't nice come on Bernie Santa with a
dual dual screen setup and you want my
financial support okay I don't think so
oh god it's a Minecraft button don't
know Oh God it is more very nice very
nice
Bernie sander memes gets infinite
financial support Thank You next mean
now I understand this is a bit
controversial you can't really joke
about stuff then can you I can't tell
disclaimer okay just cuz I laugh at
something does not mean I think it's
funny if anything it's the opposite just
so we're clear her
I'm only reviewing this for the sake of
historical context and it would be
dishonest and disingenuous for me to not
to review the coronavirus or as I like
to call it Corona wifeís because she's
hot
I would [ __ ] her I'm not gonna lie if I
wasn't married of course if I wasn't
married I don't know if I don't know I
don't know what these images are for I
don't know where they taken I don't know
if it relates to any current event but
they are so goddamn good
I love them so much it's not funny
really but also it's hilarious this is
every single pharmacy in Tokyo right now
it's wipe out and you know why because I
bought the whole goddamn stock Japan I'm
sorry for those of you don't know I was
in Japan during the outbreak and I come
back and I'm like oh through phew I made
it first headline brightened GP practice
closes after staff member tested
positive damn typos no I don't care how
hard to top this she's not going there
me she's not going there me
experts say deadly war virus can be
killed by alcohol and high temperatures
you've gotta be kidding me
there's barely any alcohol in Corona can
we stop making this joke only pitch boys
drinks corona that's right jolla sorry I
know you like Corona can I drink through
this
imagine getting jumped by a group of th
people and one of them you listen if you
think there's a racist joke even Chinese
people aim Japan made these jokes okay
it's fine you're allowed to make joke
that does not make it funny though
your girlfriend comes home from her
vaccinations in China and gives you a
kiss
she starts coughing uncontrollably this
is so saying can we send a love and
support once again to Linus tech tips
this is another meme that appeared while
I was gone Linus has been a meme before
with him but now this image of Linus he
posted he's thinking about retiring it's
such a sad video and then his face just
becomes what a cruel fate girls cry at
the end of notebook boys it's not even I
said girls you don't know how true
sadness boys you don't know true sadness
when you accidentally press restart
instead the power when you say easy in
chat and end up losing me yeah
bless your heart Linus I will not review
your meme either respect world's second
largest technological military and
economic power bad soup bad soup
delicious nom nom nom I love it so much
I just can't help myself I just can't
stop eating bad soup I love it so much
where's that that mean with a cat can't
wear space mask
yeah oh my god oh wow that'll do it
oh god it's not funny it's not funny but
also that looks like a freaking Kojima
Son video game boss battle or some [ __ ]
what the hell like if Chinese people are
joking about it then I can as well how
people react to deadly disease
eighteen twenty nineteen twenty twenty
twenty memes it's a coping mechanism
they're bad here it is there better not
be some huge meme happening while I'm
gone okay that's gonna piss me off I
don't know what I'm more mad of that I
missed this me more the fact that is a
global epidemic outbreak
checkmate coronavirus checkmate the only
reason the corona virus is still alive
is because I haven't reviewed it yet
alright guys with great power comes
great responsibility then did it work
we have Ricardo on our side guys it will
be fine alright god I look [ __ ] crazy
now all memes aside stay safe
wash your hands dispose of items that
you coffin and all that yada yada
wow so responsible thank you thank you
just wanted to say quick thanks for all
the warm welcome back yesterday very
nice I very much appreciate it I mean it
really means a lot thanks to everyone
for subscribing 68% 68% are subscribed
subscribe now for more daily content and
I see you guys tomorrow
feels good to say hey though hey hey
[Music]
you